okay in this lesson we're going to talk
about imaginary numbers and complex
numbers something that's tested on the
act and something you want to understand
so a quick review here is understanding
you know what is i equal to well i
represents the square root of negative
one okay so you just want to memorize
that i equals the square root of
negative 1. so if you were simplifying a
square root like say for example the
square root of negative 16 you could
write this as the square root of
negative 1 times the square root of 16.
the square root of negative 1 gives you
i
okay for imaginary and the square root
of 16 is 4. we usually put that
coefficient in front of the i so this
would be written as 4i
okay
so i to the first is
equal to square root of negative 1. now
i squared
is really equal to
i times i which is square root of
negative 1 times square root of negative
1 which is like square root of negative
1 squared the square and the square root
are inverses of each other so that i
squared just equals negative 1. that's
also something good that you want to
memorize
okay so i squared is negative 1.
okay
i cubed is really like i squared times i
to the first i squared is negative 1
times i gives us negative i okay so i
cubed is negative i and then i to the
4th is actually i squared times i
squared which is negative 1 times
negative 1
which gives you positive 1. and then
what happens is it repeats so you've got
i to the fifth i to the 6th i to the 7th
i to the 8th
9 10 11 12 and it repeats like that so
if you have i to a higher power like i
to the 73rd you can figure out based on
that pattern and i'll show you another
way to solve this problem as well now
complex numbers they're part real part
imaginary so if you had 3 plus 2i
okay that's a complex number part real
part imaginary and you can add complex
numbers subtract them multiply divide
and that's what we're going to go
through in
the next couple examples so
go ahead and see if you can do these
ones on your own and then we'll go
through them together so the first one
is you know what is i to the 23rd equal
can you simplify that down so go ahead
and pause the video solve this problem
and then check your answer and we'll go
through it so i to the 23rd you can
easily either use this technique of
understanding that it repeats every 4
and say well hmm i the 23rd let's see 4
goes into 23 how many times well let's
see that's 5 times that's 20 remainder
3. so i go 1 2 3 4 1 three four five
times and i would go one two
three this is going to equal negative i
now another way to do this and the way
that i actually prefer is i'd say okay i
squared
to the 11th power that's 22
with one left over now i squared is
negative 1
a negative 1 to an odd power is negative
1 times i gives you negative i so you
can think about how many times 2 goes
into 23 okay and write that as a product
of
you know an exponent raised to an
exponent and then whatever's left over
is here and simplify or you can use this
technique of repeating every four
okay so the next one
see if you can do this one on your own
simplify i over 3 plus i and remember
you don't want to have i in the
denominator that's considered improper
so see if you can solve this one we'll
go through it together
okay so what we're going to do here is
we're going to multiply
by the conjugate the complex conjugate
so if this was minus i would multiply by
3 plus i since it's 3 plus i and
multiplying by 3 minus i you just want
to change the sign in between those two
quantities whatever you do the
denominator you want to do to the
numerator so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to distribute the i so that gives
us let's see i'll put it down here
that's 3i minus i squared
and then in the denominator you can do
the foil or you can do the distributive
property twice 3 times 3 is 9.
3 times negative i is negative 3i
i times 3 gives you positive 3i and i
times negative i gives you negative i
squared okay now you can see the
negative 3i and positive 3i cancel
i squared is negative 1 times this
negative is positive 1 plus the 9 is 10
okay and then i squared is negative 1
here times a negative is positive 1
plus 3i now a lot of times you know on
the act they'll just leave it like this
technically you want to split these up
into two parts the real and the
imaginary separately like this i divided
them both by 10
but usually on the act from what i've
seen from the practice test they usually
just leave it like this
okay another example same idea you don't
want to have that i in the denominator
so go ahead and see if you can simplify
this one on your own we'll go through it
together
go ahead and pause the video so what i'm
going to do here is i'm just going to
multiply by the
complex conjugate so 2 plus i right
and then i'm going to foil the
numerators together and the denominators
together now one thing you'll notice is
that the inside and the outside they
cancel see how these cancelled so you
just end up getting the first 2 times 2
is 4 and the last which is negative i
squared
now in the numerator i'm going to
distribute that's going to give us let's
see 8 plus 4i
and this is going to give us 2i plus i
squared
okay now i squared is negative one times
a negative is positive one plus four is
five
this gives us 6i
for 4i plus 2i i squared is negative 1
plus 8 is 7. so we get 7 plus 6i over 5
or you can split it up into two parts
like i did on the last one seven-fifths
plus six-fifths i
so
you know definitely there's a question
or two about imaginary numbers on the
a-c-t so make sure you understand how to
work with i and you'll be able to do
those problems
on a ct